I have made so many typos over the years  but it's finally happening it's here  Twitter has given me early access to  test the new edit button wait what  should my first edited tweet be usually  it's not on purpose it's an accident  usually make a typo or something 31 FPS  is the best  frame rate tweet  send  all right so you can see people are kind  of on to us and uh maybe a little bit  confused but this is this is when we  edit the Tweet here so there's the edit  tweet button  yep only Twitter blue subscribers gotta  fix that real quick 30 FPS this is an  edited tweet you're welcome update  oh wait I said you're welcome let me fix  that so that's what it looks like you  can see that they're showing you the  older versions of the tweet and the  engagement with the old button and  that's what it looks like when someone  edits their tweet I will never make  another typo again I'll never tag the  wrong account I'll never spell anything  wrong  it's it's awesome